Jhansi McKinley hello John you look at
the great shape that John see McKinley's
in everything right to you it's it's uh
it's amazing what do you do to stay in
shape chase an eight and a ten year old
and the 21 year old with special needs
all around southern Lawson in Southern
California the children yeah that's the
the children you know I wish Oprah would
do a thing you know all they ever do is
diets right try the stress diet sprinkle
some stress on it yeah stress really
does or depression depressions are
really good one - yes the depression
diets rough yeah it is look if you go
either way right some people go the
wrong way with depression diet some
people they fatten up yes and people
fatten up and then this is hungry you
just can't eat yes it's most most male
Irish donkeys of which I never one since
we just blame ourselves for everything
and just we just want to slam our head
through drywall yeah so that the stress
died it's great for us
are you a puncher do you punch walls and
stuff no I beg my forehead into things
you do that's almost rain Manish yeah
it's really dysfunctional so you you
value if you ever hurt your head doing
that no what do you normally hit with
your head drywall oh it is you just
gives a little that's the key yes yes
long as you're not on the stud right
have you made that mistake it's not
going anywhere so when you need to smash
your face into something you
specifically look for drywall no it's
just whatever is close right you just
makes me think do you remember the first
time we found out what was in those
highway barriers in speed when those
yellow buckets when piano finally hits
it and they're full of water yeah right
right yeah you never really knew that
before was that thing yeah exactly right
exacto knife me why I just thought so
you've been banging your head your whole
life no as an adult he just started as
an adult yeah I take it you're sober
yeah so but what is the stress because I
think a lot of people look at you and if
you're gonna be a working actor you have
a pretty ideal career in a sense that
you've been working forever
you've been working regularly like
you're in everything you're always in
something there's always something that
you're doing it seems like you've got as
far as actors go a pretty great life
yeah this has been I mean I'm a I'm I'm
a worker bee
I've didn't once I got on that film
trained like a couple years out of
school I got an I got in a film and then
it seemed like once you got on that that
kind of that motion of getting on that
train and you get in that fraternity of
of New York actors who who can be put in
as the number six seven and eight guy
and then you know you climb the ladder a
little bit but I never got off the film
train I was just doing five or six films
a year and I didn't have any criteria
for what they could or couldn't be it
wasn't you know you're 24 25 26 30 70
years old he's go and then one seemed to
lead to another I have no idea if that's
true but they did seem to lead to each
other which but soon the third thing you
did the third film yeah third film how'd
you pull that up I was looking at your
IMDB yeah and I tell him you know it
yeah I got hired by tell me you're
looking at no I'm gonna have to look
back anyway thought you were Wall Street
was right after that was it the year
after that
important on 4th of July with that today
means one leaning to the other folks
when Oliver Stone is actually making
films and goes I like you yes yeah and
plus people Tim tend to to buy the noise
you know the if you're good enough for
Oliver you must be good for about Ryan
people buy that stuff and so we traded
on that for a while that if you were in
Wall Street and and and platoon but then
I did talk radio at the public for two
years and then Oliver optioned it and
then he shot that so that just was
completely coincidental I I had that had
nothing to do with Oliver till he bought
it and then he put Erik in it and I had
created the role which is what you say
when you're the first guy who did it and
then we went down to Dallas and we shot
it in four or five weeks so what
stresses you at them it's kind of the
question like if you start working early
right you're in your 20s you're doing
really well like you said you never got
off the train you got a series stand
against evil you're staying you know
meaning what what is stressful being a
better father trying to participate in a
more active way in creating bridges in
this between the special needs community
and and people who disparage people with
Down syndrome trying to raise more money
for autism awareness and autism research
because everybody who has Down syndrome
we'll get autism or is either double
diagnosed and will get Alzheimer's and
so I'm obsessed with Alzheimer's and as
it impacts our community the Down
syndrome community and so stuff like
that yeah stuff that I can't sleep about
thinking how I can communicate better
with people to maybe find a better word
than [ __ ] and [ __ ] and how much
that hurts our community and stuff like
that stresses me out how many get you
angry yes yeah how many kids are special
needs yeah
my son Max was born with Down syndrome
he's 21 year old he's great he's working
in Starbucks and he's doing this thing
but you know there's a lot of people who
are not doing their thing and they it's
a struggle - every day is a struggle so
that's that's what stresses me out yeah
I would imagine I didn't know that the
it leads to Alzheimer's no you will it
doesn't lead to you will get if you live
long enough
uh-huh and you were born with Down
syndrome you will arrive at Alzheimer's
so that makes it really a special
research petri-dish
research because we will not get hard
fatty tumors so how come you won't get
hard fatty tumors but you will get
Alzheimer's and for baby boomers there's
about to be an avalanche of Alzheimer's
and there's no infrastructure in place
for it nobody knows what it is
aside from brain plaque nobody knows
what to do about it there's a lot of us
are going to get Alzheimer's a lot and
there's nothing there's nothing yeah and
so all of a sudden that makes a Down
syndrome community in a research
capacity very valuable and we've traded
on that Wow that's enabled us to raise
money yeah I mean totally because you
because you can see right here okay we
know this is gonna happen correct so why
we can start here right plus it's a
disadvantage of living longer you know
what we're designed to live like what 40
or 50 years maximum the body through
yeah my doctor I had a doctor tell me
that's why you break down he said your
body is designed to live forty-five
years or whatever
everything else is medicine in science
so like all the [ __ ] that happens when
you get old all these cancers and all
these things it's part of it is just
because we're that's really interesting
ourselves live longer you know
technology hasn't fully caught up yeah
those are the design of the machine yeah
it suppose you hate to quote the machine
breaks down we break down I Jack watch
your films but yeah that's what happens
you're supposed to break down after a
certain time and drop dead but now we
can live to her 80 yeah and while this
[ __ ] goes wrong yeah can brain Falls a
partyer no tumors oh yeah I'm just
bummed because I I got rejected by
Starbucks I get max to write to a do you
like do you like working on the series
in the sense that it's regular work I
mean obviously it's a lot more work than
a film right and especially going on the
third season I'm the producer of stand
against evil and the most the only
reason I tell you that is because what I
get to do is a producer the number one
thing I get to do is Shepherd the tone
like somebody here has to decide how you
guys the tone of this show or if maybe
collectively you do but withstand
because it's a horror comedy tone wise
it lives if the if the two ends the
extremes of the spectrum are the
Exorcist which is really scary but you
cannot drop a joke and The Exorcist and
scooby-doo which is funny but at times
scary and so we live right in the middle
there somewhere where where our witches
are I want them scary but I don't want
them to cannibalize the jokes and I
don't know the jokes to be at the
witch's expense and so it's right in the
middle there with an American Werewolf
in London the one that we grew up
watching with Griffin Dutton
not the remake and that's a hard hard
tone to maintain yeah yeah because it's
really easy to get sloppy that the jokes
you can just you know you can just take
the piss out had certain moments that
work - that was a really scary movie yes
right and and and Bruce ah oh my god
Campbell Bruce Campbell is really funny
the best that kind of worked where they
didn't accomplish
scary stuff and counsel though the
series oh I think nobody had led to ash
and Bruce who I did a an arc with on on
Burn Notice down in Miami and he's great
and that show I guess and went for four
or five years and they were doing the
same thing that was comedy hard they had
a much bigger budget than us and so we
have to make do or do without but the
trade-off for having a tiny budget is
that they gave they give us almost
complete creative autonomy which is
fabulous it's also a pain in the ass you
have to okay here you have the keys to
the car and if it's just the bed it's on
you
exactly there's no one to blame but you
I'm good with that
and it's standing us evil it's season
three is on IFC October 31st it starts
like it's Halloween night 10 p.m. which
is a good time because a lot of people
are home by that at least younger people
at home like that you think also you
went you were in a play that I almost
went to see but I overslept I had Bobby
Cannavale E and Pacino I wanted to see
Pacino play Shelley in XII Lunger
England Yarra Glen Ross and I I knew you
and that I was the store the straw that
stirs the drink I'll think of his name
is Ray Harris character oddly hold on
not oh my god think it in a second I
know it's driving me crazy tearing has
lapses well yeah that was the greatest
experience of my Dave Moss I get to play
Dave Moss and he kind of is the catalyst
for everything that goes wrong in that
play and kind of all he was robbed Ricky
Roma right yes he was bulletproof he's
great
the ensemble then David Harbour who's
now the star of stranger things yeah
played in that with this as well so the
ensemble and Richard shift played Aaron
oh and so that was that that was the
greatest experience of my acting's life
it was right yes I saw that with Alan
Alda playing my jelly bean yeah it was
really it wasn't it Lea played the Ricky
Roma yeah I heard it was cool Jeffrey
Tambor yeah I loved it oh good pretty
good ensemble yeah the movies hard to
top to I mean the movie with it with the
yeah but the play is very different than
the movie here's why the movie unfolds
very casually on this rainy night and I
keep we keep going back and forth from
different places
and thing the the meter the pace of the
movie is much more casual than the play
the first act of the play is about 32
minutes and you're out on 44th Street
wondering what the hell just happened
and then you come back and the office
has been robbed and all hell's right how
did it start the play I don't remember
the plants been lay starts in three
different tables at the Chinese
restaurant their first one is where
Shelley the Machine Levine is trying to
get some leads from the head of the
office then the stage goes black and
then it comes up you're at another table
you're with me and Richard shift and I'm
telling Richard shift he should rob this
place and then you this stage goes black
and you come up on Bobby Cannavale II
trying to trying to con a mark that's
right that's the end of the first act
and it happens it's it's a freight train
and it's David Mamet wrote it he told me
he wrote it as a one-act but you can't
win a Tony with a one-act on Broadway so
he broke it up he put in anything say
did he get what he wanted did it win
anything I can't remember that was rate
that was like nineteen eighty to ninety
eighty three I went to the original two
nights in a row so it was a little
original to remember
yeah Joe Mantegna created the role of
and then all those Chicago actors that
would he'll play Roma oh he did he's so
good he created it in Chicago he came
with it and that was during the Chicago
invasion of New York from Steppenwolf to
Mamet's group they just all the Chicago
actors Malkovich Denis they invaded New
York there was rate when I was going to
school and they just brought a hold of
his whole new vibrance and sledgehammer
to the theater I remember I was
yesterday he was great in [ __ ] house
of games no Mamet Joe Montaigne he's the
best yeah
what was your was the greatest
experience before that you said that you
knew then this is the greatest
experience of my acting career well what
did it be that was before that and I
don't mean beeped out like competitively
but just one day I guess I guess platoon
yeah was the most intense and the most
well realized because you're at home and
you're reading a script and you
obviously you see it in your brain as
you're reading it and you can
and you do all these things and you have
a million different imaginations about
these words and then it never realizes
fruition and it's it's desperately
disappointing when you put four months
of your life aside you go to some random
faraway place and then the film comes
out and it sucks and you can't have the
time back and it's not the way you saw
it but you're just a hired gun on you're
an actor you came you hit your spot you
said your lines
you poured all your stuff into it and
then the film sucks and it just it takes
little pieces of you away and it smashes
them and so when they when the when from
the script through you and the director
and then up on the screen it it's it
comes somewhere near what you thought
about when you read that thing it's
thrilling and it hardly ever happens
does that still affect you could I mean
you've done so much stuff that's worked
you know I mean you've been a lawyer
your life into something you know maybe
you take two months beforehand to either
research or you bring your acting
teacher in and you break the script down
and you deconstruct the words and then
you put them back together and now you
ship off away from your family for a
while
or maybe you bring your family with you
and now you're in it you're getting it
all over you and you focus you have
blinders on like a Kentucky Derby horse
and this is what we're doing and then
four months later it comes out and
somebody [ __ ] the bed you just want to
punch somebody in the [ __ ] esophagus
we were watching a movie that he and I
didn't it was not a particularly good
film it's horrible
oh you being harder and I cringe
watching it like do you when you watch
something like that do you go or do you
get annoyed or to get him back I get
annoyed you don't get embarrassed no you
have enough faith in you in your work we
don't know what he's a real life he's a
real actor so was their performances so
that's why it's embarrassing it's
related by me I for some reason was
having an artistic man crush on Orson
Welles about and his voice primarily I
think he'd already passed and I was I
got cast in Highlander number two and so
I had to go down to Buenos Aires with
Sean Connery and so it was this this big
thing and I was gonna finally get paid
after you know you don't get paid for a
platoon and you should be so lucky to be
in Wall Street and you don't get paid
for all this [ __ ] and finally we made us
to end and you know I think I was going
to get 50 grand to go down to the point
azari's and play the third
bad guy and so I decided that since I
didn't occupy that much real estate in
the film I was gonna you're gonna hear
me differently and so I decided I was
going to lower my voice about two
octaves and so I hired a voice teacher
here in New York this one is living in
the West Village and I just brought my
voice way down based on it wasn't
supported by anything in the film no it
was bad looping on my foot it looked
like they put some other actors voice
every time I spoke in the film I look
like a [ __ ] donkey
Highlander number two Troy just horrible
and you and you look back on anger wish
you had not made that choice McKinley
what were you thinking lowering your
voice to octaves what do you what do you
gotta get your head out of your ass
sometimes well around Citizen Kane in
Tampa I just wanted to be way down here
and I thought it would be much more
threatening and slike dude just say the
lines but you work with Connery that's
gonna be fun he did Sean I'd I've done
two with him it's not that fun well is
he hard uh he does three takes and ghost
we used to just do three takes I did the
rock with him as well do three takes and
go back to his trailer and it's like
really there's 160 of us here and you
can do three [ __ ] takes and go back
to your trailer so he's like you got
three trucks and I said did you fight
with him no no I didn't have any
interaction with the mold at all on the
rock let's see no not oh yeah he fight
we we have a battle to the death in the
rock or with this nut man and who the
three takes regardless of how good they
are he'll come back and do more but
yesterday three three does he always
nail it his career was pretty good yes I
killed he'll hit it at one point I guess
I mean you're gonna get Sean Connery's
he's not gonna all of a sudden do
Elephant Man you know he does that guy
so direct the director has no say in the
matter if he wants to do direct the
needs a fourth or fifth take this off
Conor I'm not really stroke because even
if you're good you should still be a
part of the process right you're still a
piece of the puzzle
not one percent yeah especially if we're
out on Alcatraz and there's a you know
160 man crew 40 40 actors who have 200
people
think we could go again did you say no
and go back to the trailer I guess it
was no wasn't even that it was standard
operating procedure like it's contracted
or something you got three techs from a
max I don't know again I was hired guns
on these and I was just felt like Shawn
was gonna hand me his golf club bag and
tell me to carry to the next hole at any
given second he knows he's royalty oh
yeah oh yeah yeah but you're like you
know by the time the rock is out you're
like I've done some work to Shawn you
know I'm a little bit James Bond he's a
legend yeah yeah but there's a hierarchy
everyone I said watch Connery as a kid
yeah everyone watched they said Tom
Cruise said that when they did a few
good men because I'm wondering if you
ever fanboy out he said when Nicholson
was on set at that point even people who
were used to it and used to being around
people there's a feeling there's a
feeling that something is different when
he was there Nicola on the day that Jack
was on set yeah um I I haven't I haven't
fanboy doubt with actors I think I did
it with athletes more like I saw Don
Mattingly once and having grown up a
Yankee fanatic I just I had nothing to
say yeah I was like just dawn it's
Donnie baseball I'm like I didn't have
anything to say I was at that final game
that he played in Yankee Stadium I think
it was it was the against Seattle five
game series in 95 and feathers of stupid
I am Ruben Sierra hits a home run I'm
going in to get a hot dog Mattingly's up
he had like [ __ ] his seven homers and
49 runs batted and that year was a
terrible year because it was back and
his final home run in Yankee Stadium in
that playoff game I'm buying a hot dog
and I'm watching on a TV monitor to see
the homerun yeah you're not I stay in my
seat a bad year I feel this type of good
time to go get a think of me you figured
wrong dude I will never forget ordering
there was nobody in front of me and
watching it and hearing the roar of the
crowd you [ __ ] you know you know that
your decision was a bad one nobody was
in front of you everybody knew we should
stay in our seats there were even flat
screens back
[ __ ] TV piece of [ __ ] tube TV
everybody knows what they're seeing I
was almost out I was walking down I was
walking like a round right before you go
back down those the hallway yeah and I
and and and Ruben I want to say Ruben
was right before him I think he was I
don't remember what do you what do you
think this they got a shot against the
red sox-yankees you still believe that
last series of the season now the Red
Sox fans thinking like we weren't even
trying we weren't using our starters I
don't care that last series at the end
of the season to me it was tantamount to
the Giants giving that undefeated
Patriots team all they could eat that
last I'm gonna of the undefeated season
and then they were 12 point dogs and
Superbowl and they beat him of course
but at the Meadowlands that final score
was like 42 38 or something yeah but the
Giants gave him all they could eat and
this feels like that this feels like
every everybody's starting to get back
into a groove everybody's help not
everybody but maybe Chapman maybe this a
couple of days arrests gives him maybe
that gets fresh judges that risk feels
good I like everybody everybody's
starting to feel good that's gonna be a
big series I've watched people years I
watch this I actually watched some of
this last this was a six or seven to the
final yeah I actually started watching
that for the first time in years I just
lost interest in base it was a great
game when you armors are pretty good I
thought they're calling me Davey Bombers
when you are in any given Sunday right
yes when you're interviewing Willie
Beamen and it's when you know will
you've been successful so your character
all of a sudden is this big fan and you
look at him and you say you're smack is
so fresh was that your line or was that
Oliver's nose mine I love it so much do
his eternal credit let me hang out with
him because it was kind of a I made him
halfway gym and halfway Lenny Bruce and
it was back when the Museum of Broadcast
had more information than maybe your
iPad did and so I once the Museum of
Broadcast and I watch all those Lenny
Bruce stuff and I just wanted to get his
rat-a-tat-tat
and I wanted this guy to be really
accelerated and so I stole that from
Lenny Bruce and then Jim let me hang out
with him for a day and a half when he
had Roma's burning on the Fox lot and
then he had his radio show over towards
Burbank and that was unbelievably useful
you never pick stuff up watching him do
his thing and what like you just
what did you learn like cadence or
certain ways of addressing a sports
situation yeah just I just was getting
Jim's vibe and that's what I want I just
want a vibe because these these actors
get remember every time you go in front
of a camera it's like the camera is an
x-ray machine it just sees right the
[ __ ] through you and so if you can
somehow find a way to reduce the the
profundity of the lie
what is profundity mean he knows I don't
how how easy I was the lion regis the y
is in the words I'm not I'm not I'm not
stand I'm not dr. Cox I'm not sergeant
O'Neal but if for platoon Oliver put us
through that through three week boot
camp and that starts to reduce then you
can take your leap the leap of
imagination as an actor and then that
reduces how egregious the lie is and the
camera buys it just a little more and so
if you can find a way to attach to this
whoever it is your plan I mean DeNiro
put it on steroids human Dorian Raging
Bull he he was Jake LaMotta the wheat
that's who he was and so for for for all
with Jim I just wanted to get it on me a
little bit okay I just wanted to get the
vibe on me the line is so perfect
because he's sitting there like he's
this obnoxious like sports host and he's
all eagle for the first half of the
movie and then Willie Beamen starts to
become this celebrity football player
and all you want all your character
wants to do is be accepted by him all
you want to really be min to think that
you're cool so you're trying to talk
like Willie Beamen talks and you say
your smack is so fresh and Willie Beamen
is just like what are you talking about
alien language try him desperately
trying to get some street cred yeah
exactly it's just an exercise in being a
jackass I can't tell you how many times
I've said that to people and not half of
them don't even know what I'm talking
about just look at somebody your smack
is so fresh so fresh I did the same
thing I did this film set it off with
Latifah and and and and Jada Pinkett and
it's about these four women robbing
banks and so I'm the cop chasing them
it's kind of a harvey keitel role I'm
sure he turned it down and that's why I
got it but lieutenant Carr moment no
and so I I have a female assistant cop
and she says something in the middle of
the movie and I say do you feel me and I
wanted to be very Street but I don't
want it to be Street right and so that's
that's another one of those moments
where I I found something and I was like
oh I'm gonna exploit the hell out of
this yeah you have to figure out how to
fake being fake yeah because I could
make it as Street as you want but the
character can't exactly exactly right
yeah one of my favorite one of my
favorite parts you ever had was in
office space when you play like
corporate guy that comes it was a big
company so played him so well just that
goofy guy that comes in to put that fake
laugh I was a good brokers left you know
how when you're looking at apartments
with some broker and the like right
there and you go with the bathroom small
like yeah but you're gonna love it blow
up no chance no chance III had my judge
was nice enough to at first that
character was supposed to be down in
Austin Texas which is where we shot it
it was boarded which is film talk for
how long you're gonna be here there's a
there's a board and I was boarded for
two weeks but then out of nowhere I get
this Matthew Perry comedy up in Toronto
for Warner Brothers and I was going to
get paid and so I called my judge and I
go could i but the two weeks was too
much I wasn't gonna be able to go up to
Toronto right and do this thing for
three months and be in Austin for the
two weeks so I said Mike could we could
we compress this a little bit and he's
such a mensch he totally did I went down
to Austin I did I traveled on Monday did
wardrobe on Tuesday we shot Wednesday
Thursday Friday and I was in Toronto by
Saturday and the only reason that's
great is once again if you can all of a
sudden just put those blinders on and
for three days not come up for air and
just stay in that yeah usually it's
three months which is much harder to
stay in it but for three days we just
were in that interior doing downsizing
we were down cisors all of a sudden you
get in you start to get in a rhythm
whatever whatever that rhythm is you
start to find a rhythm and it's groovy
and that's what everything that could
have gone right for those three days
went right right there was a lot of
improvisation which it improvisation
always works better if it's compressed
yeah if it goes on too long there's a
lot of fat on the bone right and you
start to embellish instead of driving
through whatever you're starting to
drive through and if you become good at
improvisation you can embellish the
living [ __ ] out of anything and that's
not gonna make it in the film you know
we got to go the film's 90 minutes we
got to go or a comedy like office space
and so that everything could have gone
right for those three days did right
yeah well it never happens